welcome back I just want to do a couple
more of these problems just so you
I guess just see a couple more problems
and get some practice so let's start
with another problem as always let me
draw my triangle I always like to draw a
little different to confuse you let's
say that this angle up here is is 0.36
radians that angle is 0.36 radians and
then this side right here this top side
let me do it in a different color this
top side and pink is square root of 73
units long or whatever you know could be
inches or feet or whatever but it's
square root of 73 units long so my
question is what is this side here this
green side well how did we do this type
of problem last time we should figure
out what sides we're dealing with you
know we're dealing with the adjacent and
the opposite the adjacent and the
hypotenuse the opposite and the
hypotenuse and then we'll know which
trig functions we should be dealing with
so we know this side this pink side and
this pink side you should it should be
almost second nature by now is the
hypotenuse right it's the longest side
it's opposite the right angle so we know
the hypotenuse and what are we solving
for well this is the angle we know so
we're solving for the opposite side so
we're solving for the opposite side and
we know the hypotenuse so what trig
function will we probably use let's
write let's write out our mnemonic so
CAI Toa so what did I say before we're
solving for the opposite side and we
know the hypotenuse so we are going to
use the opposite and the hypotenuse so
which of these is that the opposite of
the hypotenuse is the oh and the H right
it's so right and so says that sine is
equal to the opposite over
the hypotenuse sine of an angle in this
case it's this angle sine of 0.36
radians
remember this is radians we're dealing
with not degrees is equal to the
opposite side and the opposite side is
this green side right here so I'll just
write opposite instead of writing oh
because it would look like a zero is
equal to the opposite side over the
hypotenuse all right this is just sine
is equal to opposite over hypotenuse
well what's the hypotenuse length
well it's square root of 73 square root
of 73
these are peas by the way I know they
don't look like peas but opposite four
opposite so the opposite side we're just
multiplying both sides by the square
root of 73 is equal to the square root
of 73 times the sine of 0.36 radians now
once again I don't know what the sine of
0.36 radians is in my head but I'll tell
you the answer the sine of 0.36 radians
is equal to I'm just rewriting this the
sine of 0.36 radians if you look it up
on a table or if you use your calculator
in Radian mode is 3 square roots of 73
over 73 and of course your calculator is
going to give you something I'll give
you some decimal number won't write it
this way but if we so just remember this
is this and I just look that up there's
no magic there and the square root of or
you could use the calculator on the Khan
Academy when you do problems it'll
actually tell you what it is so you can
you don't have to use a calculator so
now we just simplify square root of 73
times square root of 73 is 73 which over
73 is equal 1 so these all cancel out
and we get the answer of 3 so this side
right here is 3 and just how to cure
acid if you wanted to solve for this
side there's two ways we could do it
right we could use the Pythagorean
theorem because you know a squared plus
B squared is equal to C squared or we
could use trigonometry I'll let you
guess what
trig function actually let's let's do
that let's let's use it let's figure out
that side using trigonometry and then
let's use that saw figure out that side
using the Pythagorean theorem just to
show you that everything fits together
in math so let me so I wrote that three
there so I can erase all of this stuff
let me let me erase it
I shouldn't have reached the sohcahtoa
actually we should have that memorized
by now sohcahtoa so katoa all right so
let's figure out what this or inside is
here and if you think about we could do
it a bunch of ways we could say well
this is the adjacent side right because
we know the opposite we know the
hypotenuse so we could either use we we
know the the opposites we would say we
could say what what trig function uses
the opposite and the adjacent well
that's the tangent function right so we
could say tangent of 0.36 let's call the
side a right a for adjacent tangent of
0.36 is equal to the opposite three over
the adjacent over a is there another
trigonometry way we could think about
this but we also know the hypotenuse
what trig function uses the hypotenuse
and the adjacent well if you remember so
Chi Toa Chi a cosine is adjacent over
hypotenuse so we could say cosine of
0.36 is equal to adjacent over square
root of 73 I'll just write sohcahtoa
here just so you can confirm that what
I'm doing right the Toa says the tangent
is equal to the opposite three over the
adjacent and Chi tells us the cosine is
equal to the adjacent over the
hypotenuse so we could solve either one
of these if we use the second formula we
the adjacent side is equal to the square
root of 73 times the cosine of 0.36 and
then if you use your calculator in
Radian mode or I'll just tell you that
cosine of 0.36 radians is equal to 8
square roots of 73 over 73 and you could
confirm that by getting a decimal number
and then make a making sure once again
your calculator is not in degree mode in
Radian mode I think that's actually the
default mode a lot of calculators and
solving for this but once again the 73
this 73 square root of 73 times this
square root of 73 is equal to 73 and
then divided by 73 these all cancel out
how convenient um and you get 8 so the
jacent side is equal to 8 and so if we'd
solve for a here using the tangent
function we should have also gotten the
adjacent sine is equal to 8 and just to
show you that everything works out from
other concepts let me show you this
using the Pythagorean theorem so what's
so 8 squared plus 3 squared should equal
should equal the hypotenuse squared
square root of 73 squared well 8 squared
64 plus 9 should equal what's the square
root of 73 squared right it's 73 and of
course 64 plus 9 is 73 and sure enough
that equals 73 so it works isn't that
interesting how math just kind of fits
together I think at this point you're
ready to try the the modules the
trigonometry 2 modules and I guess let
me know if you have any problems and
then or if you want to see more videos
have fun